SAFETY WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO CALL
WITH NINETEEN EMERGENCIES AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING HIM FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE
SUPPORTERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES. TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
HAVE ONE BILL ON OUR AGENDA
TODAY MEMBERS. SB FOUR NINE
FOUR BY SENATOR DODD AND IT'S
ON CONSENT. BECAUSE IT'S ON
CONSENT WILL NOT BE TAKING ANY
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY AFTER
SHARING. WHEN THERE'S A QUORUM.
COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL IN
LOTS OF STEPS RECALL. BRADFORD
EFFORT HERE ADOBO COM LONGER
COME LONGER HERE SKINNER WINNER
WINNER HERE IS A QUORUM.
MEMBERS THERE'S A QUORUM
PRESENT IS THERE A MOTION FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR WINNER. THE
MOTION IS THAT THE FAMILY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FOUR NINE FOUR DODD BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE INTRO BOGUE COM
LONGER COME UNDER AYE SKINNER.
WINNER WINNER I. THAT MOTION IS
OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
BUT CHOI BOGUE. FIVE TROUBLE
GUY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON IT
AB FOR M. S. B. FOUR NINE FOUR
SKINNER FIVE SKINNER AYE VOTES
FIVE ZERO. THE VOTERS FIVE ZERO
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY IS ADJOURNED.